So Jamie I hear you think it's
controversial that you do not like Star
Wars well
you know I'm not happy about it but I
have seen a bunch of people asking why
the mandalorian's so bad right now and
and is Star Wars doomed and all these
other little things and you know I think
I have something controversial to say
I like Star Wars
still welcome to side trick your TV and
movie channel
Harris it's welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV a movie channel
bloody Americans
[Music]
so Star Wars is good it definitely has
its moments where it's not perfect but
it's generally good and it's love for a
reason so let's start with where you
started your video off Jamie the sequels
aren't everyone's cup of tea mine
included they're not my favorite things
in the world
but they generally have some decent
Concepts and and we'll kind of leave it
to that for now huh so the prequels are
definitely politically oriented and they
are are very different than the original
trilogy but they still are fun yes they
are that Space Opera and they're very
operatic and politically inclined where
you know it's it's gonna be a little bit
slower and you're gonna be more involved
with what's going on in the Galaxy more
so than maybe you're fighting your
battles or something like that so I
think the prequels are kind of a perfect
example of where Star Wars
goes a little bit more into sci-fi I I
like them the ogs are fantastic and of
course I I will never say anything
otherwise they're not perfect but the OG
Trilogy is fantastic nonetheless the
dialogue is also not perfect sure
but it's purposeful and even whenever
it's not strictly purposeful it's more
funny satirical it's it's typically
funny satirical and purposeful
nonetheless I'd even argue to the acting
point from your video about Star Wars
not wanting to make a good film
sometimes
what Jamie my friend what are you
talking about we've got Alec Guinness
we've gotten Mark Hamill we've got
Carrie Fisher we've got Harrison Ford
we've got Billy D Williams we've got
Frank Oz and James Earl Jones voice
acting
all of these roles are beloved roles
not just the roles for the the actors
but the characters themselves and
that has to do with acting they're
beloved for a reason and
I think they're going to stay beloved
I I think the acting and the original
trilogies are once again
purposeful into the way that the the
stories were written and we kind of got
put into these worlds and and they're
not necessarily worlds that we're used
to which changes the way people react to
things and I I guess if it's a little
more space operatic a little fantasy
like a little Western like a little
Samurai like
you know it's
it's the way that Galaxy works and I for
one enjoy it and Jamie it's not that
George Lucas had little faith in his own
film that he didn't go to the premiere
and he went on holiday and vacationing
with Steven Spielberg it's that he had
little faith in the audience in the
1970s of course the mid late 1970s it's
it's kind of weird to have a Star Wars
film come out nothing really that
odd and peculiar had been in cinema yet
of course there were some things Star
Trek being one of them but not
necessarily to that degree and of course
oh Lucas paved the way and then
engineered the way and pioneered it for
all of us
but he had little faith in the audiences
wanting and accepting something like
that at the time and I think really
that's where he went off on holiday with
Steven Spielberg but
if we're talking about Steven Spielberg
widely considered one of if not the
greatest director of all time by many
many people
who had faith in Star Wars Steven
Spielberg did because Steven Spielberg
and George Lucas wagered each other on
who would have the more successful
sci-fi film
or space fantasy of course in Star Wars
but the more successful sci-fi film in
general it was close encounters for the
Third Kind Of course for Steven
Spielberg and George Lucas's Star Wars
turned into a New Hope later on
their wager was whoever had the more
successful film the loser I guess of the
wager technically or the winner because
they each had faith in each other's
films better than they had in their own
film or more so than they had in their
own films
the winner would get 2.5 of the proceeds
of Star Wars
suffice to say Steven Spielberg is a
very rich man so one of the greatest
producers the guy that made The Goonies
had faith and knew Star Wars was going
to be good that he knew A New Hope was
going to be good George Lucas knew it
too he just had little faith in the
audience accepting it at the time he
hoped it would be a cult classic kind of
like American Graffiti was and THX 11 11
38 11 whatever his original uh film was
which I own and I need to watch but
it's amazing the fact that he actually
wagered 2.5 percent of Star Wars Steven
Spielberg was the first director to make
a billion dollars by the way I know I'm
sidebarring but he was the first
director to make a billion dollars and a
good chunk of that was because of his
Star Wars cast
great great and okay so I I said it a
couple times just a second ago talking
about
space fantasy sci-fi Western what what
kind of genre is Star Wars
we can't look at it in that hard sci-fi
kind of way we're looking at it Jay it's
not Star Trek it's not Stargate it's not
these kind of uh more more specific
scientific based things now it's
definitely fantasy based but it's
primarily based
as a story for 12 year old boys growing
up and to have something cool and
logical to kind of help help them piece
the world together it's not supposed to
be super pertinent and scientific as
much as I love those things this is very
much a fantasy and it is a Opera at the
same time but it is a space fantasy
first and foremost so the original
trilogy was first and foremost a space
fantasy and that's kind of what Star
Wars is as a whole it's not supposed to
be logical per se it's supposed to be
magical and wondrous it's supposed to be
awe-inspiring
and I think it succeeds exceptionally in
all those fronts and
yeah it's not perfect and you know we
can go ahead and get into some of those
things that aren't perfect
like the sequels we won't stay long on
here because uh
once again they're not necessarily my
cup of tea all the time either but
they're here and you know the sequels
are the sequels and I know you discussed
the fleet on exit goal and how why how
it got built and why there were so many
ships way out in the middle of nowhere
when the Death Star was there and did it
make the Death Star pointless and yes I
am kind of
roping myself into New Canon and kind of
explaining away the way they have but I
don't hate the way they've explained it
away I don't necessarily love it but I
don't hate the way that they explained
it away so I guess Disney kind of says
that exigol was the entire giant Fleet
being built by Palpatine on hexago was
already being built Vader knew about it
etc etc
and this is where I guess the
potentiality of we're not positive if
this is where it's going to go but it
makes the most sense of Palpatine made
that Fleet further use on vong and if
the potential potentiality of the use on
Vaughn coming into the Star Wars Galaxy
comes true then this will have made
perfect sense and I will legitimately
like it a lot more than the kind of okay
y'all explain it away but still like it
so ebstical is there to fight off the
use on vong all this giant Fleet is
there to fight this giant biohacked kind
of non-force race of beings that are
trying to come into the Star Wars Galaxy
and essentially take it over
the Death Star the second death star per
se it kind of was to to
be its purpose was more so to enact as
the capital for Palpatine so Palpatine
was going to have it to kind of fly
around the Galaxy and and do what he
liked of course he could kind of have
that threatening giant Ray of death to
blow up planets but most of it was just
primarily for
not necessarily to take over what
coruscant's place was in the Galaxy but
to take over what coruscant's place was
in the Galaxy the Death Star was going
to be kind of his his roving uh personal
kind of capital and extra ghoul was
going to be the fleet to kind of back it
all up and keep everybody in check
probably but of course
primarily be for the use on vong down
the road to defend the Galaxy
and we'll see where that goes of course
and
your topic if you really delve into Star
Wars lore like you were kind of talking
about in your video about not liking it
there really aren't necessarily it's
it's there's no cookie cutter good bad
oh here's an anti-hero here's an
anti-villain like someone that's going
to be redeemed there's all of those
things and you see that in almost every
character in different ways and you have
different points and different
characters and where okay they could
definitely turn more good than they are
now or more bad than they are now and
nobody's kind of clearly defined even
Yoda in the Animated Series
toys with darkness and he toys with
Darkness
for the sake of
like like studying it in a way and and
it kind of is a a beautiful uh mismatch
with Yoda and you see that and it's just
no stone is left unturned in Star Wars
and part of the beauty of it is the fact
that no one's necessarily good no one's
necessarily bad the Jedi while trying to
do many good things are kind of
religious zealots that are are forcing a
lot of different worlds to do things
that the government that they've allied
with want them to do when a lot of these
other people are just trying to live
their simple lives without being
subjugated by a a large body of people
that aren't anywhere close to where they
are and that's just the prequels if you
get into the actual original trilogy
it gets a lot more dicey than that
because of course the rebels are
terrorist cells but death definition you
know by not just technicalities by
definition they are
for better and worse because then you
have some saw Guerrera stuff like you
see in Rogue one like you see in Rebels
and the Clone Wars a bunch and a little
bit in bad batch they're not the best
kind of rebels and and that's the guy
that happened to be an Andor as well and
you know we see him and Lutheran talk
about letting people kind of just die
inside the Rebellion these little def
different sects of rebels just kind of
either
surviving or dying on a whim and it's
a whim of their friends or one of the
people they know and that's that's not
inherently good or bad of course all
these actions are for good things
they're their purpose is for
good in in the long run but in the short
run what kind of shortcuts are you
taking and that's something that every
Star Wars project tends to ask and it's
kind of great because of that it's it's
so much fun I love asking those
questions and continuing to ask them
every step of the way
makes it feel more human whether you're
following an alien an actual human
someone that's half human human half
alien somewhere it's really fun and I
think that's one of the core elements of
Star Wars is the fact that there is not
necessarily good or bad and that's where
the force really imbues itself as well
is is the force good is the force bad
we've seen the limits of both sides
we've seen your Yodas we've seen your
Darth Vaders we've seen your palpatines
you've seen your Obi ones you you've
seen your Qui-Gon you've seen your
ahsokas and just talking about the rebel
sales and stuff Jamie you should
definitely watch The Rebel show and and
you know I I think not only does the
rebels show and and Clone Wars and bad
batch and things like that I think not
only are they
just good
wider storytelling for Star Wars that
allow you to kind of delve into smaller
characters learn about different worlds
and different planets different species
all kinds of different things that is
where you can really see George Lucas's
vision and it doesn't seem so
this is for the toys this is for that
and of course there are definitely
decisions that George Lucas and Disney
of course have made
for toy sales but if you're watching the
Star Wars animation I feel like that's
really where Star Wars opens itself up
it's it's like the bloom of a flower and
it it's just it's wonderful
it really is the stories told by Dave
filoni and George Lucas are masterful
and they're not always
perfect right off the go sometimes it
takes years for you to start loving
something
and I guess that's just a patient
Storyteller doing their things and yes
George Lucas has always been a patient
Storyteller Star Wars has never been the
fastest pace of things but that's one of
the reasons I think we love it so much
is because at the end of the day
it takes a little time to get to your
destination but the point of getting to
your destination is a lot of the time
learning and enjoying things on the
journey and that's what Star Wars is
it's the journey Star Wars isn't purely
sci-fi fantasy it's not purely a Space
Opera it's not purely a space western or
any of these things it's a beautiful
amalgamation of them all and it's it's
for the Youth which in turn helps keep
the youthful aspect the kid inside of
all of us alive and
I for one love it thank you George Lucas
and Dave filoni for making it
even if Jamie and all these other
internet people are gonna dog on it I'm
still with you I've got my kyber crystal
here I've got my Star Wars shirt right
on me and and I get one in the mail
every month I love my Star Wars so I'm
here for it no it's not perfect
because the Mandalorian a little dicey
at the moment sure maybe not
everything's for everybody but I'm
having a good time with it it's really
making my little clone wars and Rebels
hard happy
and I hope it does so even more so come
back check the patreon out on Sidetrack
check everything down below in the
description for nine Chevrons the
patreon link join the YouTube membership
channel here
and have a great day we'll see you in
the next one
foreign
[Music]